welcome to this video playing frederico
with black Frederico it's not playing
hello yeah you cannot cannot really send
him any wake up call them you never know
Joe is he going to play d4 c41 9393 b3
g3a3 what I going to do one minute now
yeah they have the 45 minutes so if if
he is popping up let's say with 30
seconds left he can still play this game
and jump still fight even with being
quite some time down yeah I have to wait
the full five minutes there are actually
some players I have witnessed that that
if they play Oleg us they em they just
left at five minute run down to torch
him because they have the same issue
that I have with this time play and okay
um let's see what to do maybe the
Queen's onion experimenting with that a
little bit yeah i recently tried
something funky there which I will not
sure will not repeat with d5 I already
have a bad position there I know that
they normally play with B takes but I
think that this line also should be
quite okay this looks a lot like um
looks a lot like a hedgehog but not
quiet
I don't have the pawn down on d6 and the
night is on c5 let's see I had a pretty
similar position recently against Greg
Shahada and one of the in the dual
commentary blitz okay so he's not
minding trades I also don't want to
achieve very much I still have those
this idea to play against them against
the sea for porn if I take with the
night I'm unsure that it could be a bit
tricky but taking with the bishop is
okay Queen a4 I just I can play Bishop
c6 of our like Queen a7 blunders the
queen but I'm not sure that I want that
Quincy seven though I can play why not
attacking rook and pawn and he's going
back yeah I can play a move like Bishop
g5 just trying to win this exchange
cutting off the rook let's see can i
play that I mean as I think I can play
the move pawn takes Queen takes it is
just cut off right let's do that Queen
a3 I take Quincy form
maybe I could have played Bishop see 694
and I'm not sure not sure here but
trapping this book cannot be bad
you can try to get a pawn for it yet
somehow my group six takes them look six
takes them ed pawn takes and it's it's
not really compensation but okay this is
another way trying to get compensation
amit i'm looking at those two points
though yeah this is it's not so it's not
completely winning ourself a black Queen
see for Queen 87
may be here for Queen 87 Queen 85
getting this traded oh yeah no it's not
it's not a super simple win here he has
a very nice night there on default
that's not okay that's a surprise I
think I can take here right quickly 6
rugby aight i get the brittle pawn hmm i
thought that that would help me really
or is he playing for night f5 business
maybe 9 f 5m that 9527 so i probably
maybe I have to check with the Queen
then it doesn't doesn't really hurt
anyway let's activate this rook
I like to see him playing III this
weakens second rank oops why can I not
take it i think i can write that's
helpful to say the least it wasn't so
late the exam wasn't so easy and i know
it's an exchange but if you go see three
down i'm at this mine rook c8 okay it
doesn't get in night f5 yeah black
should win win this somehow but it's a
it's not something that can be can be
can be played okay i don't think that
this Bishop to success is that great i
think this is helping me quite a bit
here and now whom yeah yes to do
something uncomfortable already this is
giving away the exchange i think you
know this is the the best the best line
actually that that he played them and no
probably just taking I'm sorry just
taking and he has a pretty safe pawn
there let's just say he goes here and he
goes here later at some point then the
d4 Knight will always keep the important
thing some protected c2 is protected
that's very difficult to play for win
and we play for win is easy but do doing
this with success is the problem I have
chances to win but his drawing chances
are very very serious i think okay well
thanks for watching